持って行った
こんにちは
ゴッド肇社長です今日はほか音もない
俺は昨日の夜ローズの中でる全ドリンクを買った
大迷惑だな子で題名はけど深夜に行ったんでもうお客さんも全然いなってねまぁ暇そう
だったんでまぁ良しとしましょう
もう水という水を全部買ってきました別に版引きとかそんなことしないからね
ちゃんとこちらに証拠がありますマジ万引きしてねーかんな
自腹ちゃんと買ったかんなやっぱりは常連じゃないとできなかった住んで迷惑だし本当
にありがとうございました
て上で300
5点です今度ポイント1000ポイント貯まりましたありがとうございます何にバカと
言われてももう自分でを張って分かってるからいいよな天才とバカは紙一重だからさ
まあお前ら馬鹿つっても俺はな天才に近い人間だ
まあこれマジでねちょっと一度やってみたかったんですけども
日本人のドリンクを全部集めるっていうのは無理なんでまぁ何でも揃ってるコンビニ
ですねコンビニの
全ドリンクですもうなんか色々アレはこういうなんか
このような色合いでも入選インカ栄養剤とかもアルコール以外は全部買ってきました
まあ日本人のトリガー無理なんでコンビニの全種類のドリンクを混ぜて最強のドリンク
を作ります1個1個紹介していきたいんですけどさすがにしんどいんで
なしですかいいえ御意んっ dee
はいいきゃいきゃいっていう jr いいえ俺の名前ははじめ真面目では真面目いじめ
お気楽にケジメ必要うよ
花王この花のピザしぶりーのめちゃくちゃ動画でちょっとテンション上がっている
kaon ギュッ
経営で行くかもんかをどう者ってどうやってドーム花は散っどうやって飲むかはどう
やって飲むかはそう
全部ドームのは難しいからつとローで行ってきとってこの魔法の小瓶に全部入れるよ
俺が
歴史を変える
尾崎マース今年はまた分ここらへんのペットボトルだけでも生きていけるからもう
ジュースは買うことないですこういう感じで im こういう感じに出てきます
そうねぇ
おっしゃ hype れず乳製品は終わりです
牛で費用で保存ができないから大変なちょっと全部冷蔵庫を入れてきますはい乳製品
司馬遼ははい入線石破多い
はい10製品芝乳製品も終わったのでここからは保存が利くものが多いんで
まぁこ
やってみましょう結構しんどいねー
てか300種類混ぜるってバーでしょいやダメために行ったほど行った人が開いたら
その点俺はやっぱ天才かもしれねえな
[音楽]
ん
でみたい数50のでいたですね
う早番さあずっ
[音楽]
いっ
車ラスター
8つ終わったよー
i 狩猟で得ずできました
やって300種類コンビの全種類のドリンクを混ぜた
名付けて
インフィニティー甲府いいですインフィニティ4 p ねうん
乳児に入線品が比較的多かったんでどっちかというとコーヒーチークですね
コーヒー軸ですそれこれが出ます世界で一番いろんなものを含めます
いい意味でも悪い意味でも
me ん
[音楽]
ん
q 満たしやっとってきてよ夢ドリンクが伸び大会
強引な動画者のばせられないんだと勇気で俺が身を持ってこのいいフィリピコーヒーの
レビューを知ら誰も住まずに良いから失礼します
[音楽]
あれはちょっと思ったのと違う何か災いの匂いがします
ベースはねなんだろうわけわかんないんだよなんか俺オロナミン c を土台となって
ますあとから続いてはオレンジピール
どちらのピンチとかセイロンティーというか漁る地方からのダージリンティー df
院長を醸し出してつ
くさいですいいフィニティコーヒーだもん
おいしいよあーーや前のいろんなも入っていうかな
いろんなもってレベルじゃないからな全部入ってるからな知らない知らないよ少ない
もん
全部の味がしますマジでやこれ逆にすごいな偏ってない何かマジ入れた300種類の
ジュースとがコーヒーとか牛乳とかを均等に体に流し込む感じですべての成分を均等に
受け取ってる感じ
あんまりまずくないですいやまずいけどねまずいけどそんな
亜鉛ってなんじゃなくて男女ゴールドカラーで受け付けないかな
の
[音楽]
ね
おっ
多かった
えええええ
今日は早めに寝るよ
[音楽]
います
アルコールが入ってないからねまあ君たち誰でも出来るから是非
ぜひじゃねえはやらないようにしましょう